[SPEAKER_00]: First session with Paul Rivero.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is Julian's character and kind of background information on this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll let you know that I record most of the session basically to take notes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I have this program where I put it through a translator.
[SPEAKER_01]: That puts it into text, and then I summarize it using the AI, and I give it to my players to be able to read, to remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you do this for everyone?
[SPEAKER_01]: What happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, everybody.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got programs that take care of all this stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_00]: A whole new level.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you'll get an email.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably what I'll do is create a Google Docs that you can go and click on and just see the history of everything that's happened for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you don't have to take notes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if you want to take notes, you can take notes as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, what I don't do, and this is really a huge part of the game, is I do not allow characters to listen to sessions where they're talking to other characters.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like one-on-ones?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, conversations.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or conversations with one character specific is what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the reason I do that is I like to have
[SPEAKER_01]: I like to have the interactions of people that are disagreeing about things and the way they view it and see it without there being a definitive God message, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah, it's like you know but you don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there's something you do by yourself...
[SPEAKER_01]: Or if there's a conversation with an NPC that's very important, I will sometimes let people go through and look at the transcript of that so they can remember that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that's basically because NPCs are NPCs.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, other player characters, if you have a conflict or if there's a misunderstanding or whatever, because oftentimes, and I'm not saying everybody does this, but oftentimes there'll be disagreements.
[SPEAKER_01]: And somebody will act unreasonable.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I don't want to point that out continuously for them, because I don't want their character to be affected by the fact that they are an asshole.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want them to be able to be that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, that's a whole part of the game.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's important to be mindful when you're playing with other player characters in this situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because, I mean, usually you do not get in conflict with other player characters in a way where it's like you're fighting them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though it does happen, it has happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it's only ever happened once in all seven D&D campaigns I've ever played.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in this game, there are a lot of disagreements between friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: And a lot of it occurs because of misunderstandings and miscommunications that occur.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's misremembering, which is part of the game.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that is something I want to tell you up front.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so, background of your character, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so first off, you are
[SPEAKER_01]: He's part of the noble family of the Prince of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, your mother is his younger sister, who is very beloved by Prince John II.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's only part of the noble family.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are part of the royal family.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are very much part of the royal family.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though your sister is beloved and her name was Lady Elaria, you're sort of in a strange place because when your mother was very young, probably the age of 17, 16 or 17, she became pregnant with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Out of woodlock, and it was a scandal.
[SPEAKER_01]: A big scandal.
[SPEAKER_01]: And she refused to say who the father was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, Prince John II did his best to
[SPEAKER_01]: And truthfully, a woman having a child out of wedlock in the principalities is not nearly as horrible as it is in some places, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Your culture of piracy and all of that, so bastards and whatnot, that occurs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Normally, however, the way Prince John would have taken care of this is basically said, my sister was raped, I'm gonna fucking kill that guy, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And taken care of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's always been kind of his
[SPEAKER_01]: Take on this.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's always kind of seen you as an unknown lineage.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does not hate you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not going to say he hates you.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, there's always been that tension between him and his sister.
[SPEAKER_01]: Regarding who the father was.
[SPEAKER_01]: And she has never told, she would never tell him.
[SPEAKER_01]: She would never tell him who the father is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now because of this, and actually because your mother, for whatever reason, seemed to really love the guy that was your father.
[SPEAKER_01]: Never took another
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, never got married.
[SPEAKER_01]: Never remarried.
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince John didn't push it.
[SPEAKER_01]: He felt like she was damaged goods anyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: There weren't many people in the other
[SPEAKER_01]: In the Isles, which he could have made alliances with the Commodores of the Outer Islands or even some of the princes from bigger cities.
[SPEAKER_01]: For one, he never really wanted to subject your mother to that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know this about him, because these are rough men and he wanted to keep her inside the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: He could have married her to a merchant or even some noble from another country, but because of her
[SPEAKER_01]: Forlorn love of this person, whoever it was, and you, this never happened and she never remarried, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, you, however, you were always adored by your mother.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I an only child?
[SPEAKER_01]: You are an only child.
[SPEAKER_01]: You always remember your mother there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You always remember her loving you dearly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sometime around the age of five or six,
[SPEAKER_01]: There was an accident that happened, a horrible accident that happened, or at least this is what you're told.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've asked various people that were supposedly wise people, you know, why can't I remember?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I was six years old.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was five or six years old.
[SPEAKER_01]: I should have memories at that time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, what you've been told by those of the staff at the palace that will talk to you, and there are a few.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you're generally very sullen and withdrawn.
[SPEAKER_01]: You got a charisma of six, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So really you don't have a lot of contact with a lot of people.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are some people that were, pretty much your mother was your contact to the world.
[SPEAKER_01]: She would always be there, she understood you, she would talk to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But a horrible accident happened and you were severely burned over your entire body.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are parts that are not burned, but your face
[SPEAKER_01]: Scarred.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very scarred.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your ears are nubs.
[SPEAKER_01]: You grow no hair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your upper body is like that as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the reason your charisma is so low is because physically you are hideous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now... Do I wear a mask or anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: You do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it like...
[SPEAKER_00]: King Baldwin II kind of mask, where it's a metal mask over... You can get that if you like.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you want to have that as your mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it just like a wooden... No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just trying to get an idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the thing is that you can choose.
[SPEAKER_00]: Normally...
[SPEAKER_00]: I can choose, of course, I'm just saying what do I look like right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Normally in your day-to-day...
[SPEAKER_01]: You wear a leather mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the reason you wear a leather mask is because it's not as heavy as a metal one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's quieter.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's quieter.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when you're in the castle, everybody kind of recognizes that and understands it, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: But also, you wear clothing that covers up your body because you don't want people to see your skin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Particularly your hands.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't want people to see the horror that is you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also you have some physical issues because of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing that's going to show up in the game as a disability.
[SPEAKER_01]: But basically you itch a lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's okay normally during the day when you're conscious.
[SPEAKER_01]: It can kind of get in the way of your concentration sometimes, especially when it's hot and you're having to wear leathers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oftentimes you'll retreat to your private chambers to be able to strip off the clothes you wear and wash yourself because wearing these confining clothes is horrible, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Also, the problem, because of the burns, your ability to sweat is very effective as well, and so it can be uncomfortable, and often times...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're just sweating all the time?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're sweating out of those parts of your body that still have pores.
Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is basically your back, which is fairly undamaged in the backs of your legs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most of the damage happens to your front.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But your head...
[SPEAKER_00]: It was totally burned as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And again, you don't really have a memory of what happened, but rumors have abounded and you've learned some of these through the years.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was not a normal fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in fact, some people say it was a magical fire caused by demons.
[SPEAKER_01]: And some of the more pernicious and horrible rumors were basically that your mother had taken a demon lover and he was trying to claim you back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope you weren't going to go there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But no, it's true.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, so Oeridians are pretty
[SPEAKER_01]: Superstitious people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not completely into magic or magic users.
[SPEAKER_01]: Specifically because Suel are basically sorcerers and Oeridians have always seen themselves as more of a pragmatic, practical people that do not want to delve into those weird strange things.
[SPEAKER_01]: However,
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg is a very, very cosmopolitan city and so there is magic.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean there are street vendors that sell potions, there are street vendors that sell charms, there are head wizards all over the place, and of course the
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince of Toli is somebody that has dealings with the Arcane Order, which are a group of wizards or sorcerers that live in Port Toli, in and around Port Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: So magic is not completely away from the world you live in.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, there are many practitioners of curses and magic and whatnot in the lower cities.
[SPEAKER_01]: A lot of them are foreigners, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Monmurgians, Prince Jeon's royal family,
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't do that stuff, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So this rumor was particularly annoying to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your uncle
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically has tried to eliminate that rumor completely.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's done a lot to protect you from these kinds of things.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's my uncle's name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jeon II.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's right, that's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince Jeon II.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is like the first among equals of the princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And without a doubt the most, probably the wealthiest man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Isn't he?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, he's probably the wealthiest man, not only in Sea Principalities, but far and wide, possibly with Flaness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg has become a trading center.
[SPEAKER_01]: Isn't a big naval harbor, too?
[SPEAKER_01]: They have a huge, well, not that you know of.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have a very powerful navy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wouldn't say it's the biggest navy, but their ships are the fastest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their ships are the most technologically advanced.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have a tradition of naval
[SPEAKER_01]: Dominance.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they have even been able to, through that power, keep the much larger country of Keoland away from it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they do it through fortifications, their navy, and their natural barriers.
[SPEAKER_01]: One called the Hul Marshes, which is a huge marsh that is to the west of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then the Azure Sea protects
[SPEAKER_01]: The Monmurgian Sea Principalities coastal lands because the Navy there can fight off any kind of naval attack from Keoland, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, so this has kind of been your life and in fact because of
[SPEAKER_01]: Your disfigurement.
[SPEAKER_01]: Also because of your mother's coddling.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you know this about yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have never been given the kind of responsibilities or duties that somebody who is this closely related to the Prince of Monmurg
[SPEAKER_01]: Would have been at a younger age.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, several of your cousins have been given their first commands in the Monbergian Navy at the age of 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're 23.
[SPEAKER_01]: Several of your relations have been given duties such as, you know,
[SPEAKER_01]: Captain in a mercenary guard unit or stations in the port district.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically to learn the functioning of the city and the levers of power that go into
[SPEAKER_01]: Making a trade city like Monmurg is actually work.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that's what's so amazing about the, the, um, uh, uh, Prince Jeon and your, your family is that they were a group of pirates who were very successful, but they've really quickly understood that to be able to maintain their power, they needed to have an administration and a, um,
[SPEAKER_01]: Diplomatic reach and a defensive infrastructure in place to be able to survive.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the family that you come from was all about that and they basically created Monmurg out of a pirate camp.
[SPEAKER_01]: Over the last 200 years, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So this city has grown and grown very rapidly in the last 200 years to what it is today based on the intelligence, the cohesiveness of your family and service to what your family is, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: You've been left out of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And to you it's really kind of a
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not gonna say an embarrassment, but it is upsetting.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do feel like you're being left behind.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not like your uncle is being cruel.
[SPEAKER_01]: You feel like your mother has basically kept you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Isolated and in the dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: And your uncle has tried to do a few things with you, but I think he's quickly realized that you make people uncomfortable.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's no way he could put you in command of anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You make people uncomfortable.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's no way he can put you into an office, necessarily.
[SPEAKER_01]: And because of this, you have kind of languished.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now here you are at the age of 23.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you have basically spent much of what your adulthood is
[SPEAKER_01]: Reaping histories in the library.
[SPEAKER_01]: Learning about the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're very intelligent.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, it's obvious to everyone that you're a lot smarter than most of your average.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most of the people around you, it's not even your average person.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like, actually, you are incredibly intelligent.
[SPEAKER_01]: However...
[SPEAKER_01]: Oftentimes, your insights, when you give them, are not fully understood until later, if at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, what's happened over the years is you just become more and more reclusive.
[SPEAKER_01]: And even though you are kind of tolerated, your presence is tolerated around the council because you are part of the royal family, you're allowed to come to dinners and you get to wear your nice mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you're kind of an oddity and, again,
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not really allowed to interact in the day-to-day of things.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm on my own majority of the time, is what you're saying?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well... Just because no one wants to be around me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Except your mother.
[SPEAKER_00]: Except my mother.
[SPEAKER_01]: And really, in a way, she relies on you way too much.
[SPEAKER_01]: In your opinion.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like she is very insular herself.
[SPEAKER_01]: She is very beloved by your family.
[SPEAKER_01]: She's always been very kind to people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though the scandal happened, it's obvious to everyone that you are not a product of rape or
[SPEAKER_01]: Some other horrible thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, her secrets and her... She's frozen, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: She's been frozen.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she's been that way since you were born.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean by frozen?
[SPEAKER_01]: She's not moving on with her life.
[SPEAKER_01]: She didn't want to.
[SPEAKER_01]: After this happened, some great grief occurred.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And after that happened, she basically just shut down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have I ever asked her?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or is she just not telling me?
[SPEAKER_01]: You've asked her, but she really has not given you any indication.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if you ask her, hey, who is my father, she's never told you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So anyway,
[SPEAKER_01]: This has been your life since you can remember, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: And again, you can't really remember anything before the age of six or seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then... No flashbacks of before six or anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it just blank?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well... That's an interesting question.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have had dreams.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you have had dreams of the fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually you've had dreams of...
[SPEAKER_01]: Magical little creatures that were your friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like... What do you mean by magical?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like a gnome, or...?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sprites.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: This was basically before you remembered the pain.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've had dreams of these things, but they never really meant anything to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, there was a time when you remember having friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, you always remember your mother being very, very sad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very, very sorrowful.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that was something that happened before you even got into the accident.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those are the memories you have, those are the dreams you have, but your mother has always been very, very
[SPEAKER_01]: Very sad about things and has done her best to kind of keep you away from everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in fact, whereas most kids are like given the or go to court or shown at court or are introduced to the courtliness of things, your mother went out of her way to make sure that
[SPEAKER_01]: You would not interact.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would not see.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would not have a normal childhood.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would not make friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which further reinforced your social awkwardness and your charisma.
[SPEAKER_01]: The negative two charisma.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the thing I'm going to say about you is you're not cruel unless you want to be.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you're smart enough to be cruel if you want to be.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you're not that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not saying your character is that and that's why you're not liked.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just that you are completely misunderstood and very smart and you will say things
[SPEAKER_01]: That might be a little bit too truthful at times and your mother is kind of about this because you and your mother would never have a filter on things.
[SPEAKER_01]: That does not do good for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know this.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it's kind of hard for you not to be that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if you are placating or you are trying to be
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the word?
[SPEAKER_01]: Diplomatic, I guess, is the way it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your demeanor comes off as fake.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because you just don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, people know that you're basically
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have the nuance of it, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have the ability to charm somebody, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because it's not that what you say is wrong, but when you try to be charming, when you try to emulate what you see other people do, it just comes off as like an orc trying to
[SPEAKER_01]: Bribe somebody with a piece of meat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rotted maggot or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rotting maggots or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm trying to say is you have a very hard time with social interactions and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, do you have any questions about this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where does me being a rogue, what does that desire come into?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I think that
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically you've been self-taught on how to be stealthy and a lot of this comes around from the fact that you have avoided being seen.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you go to the bathroom you don't want anybody to know where you are.
[SPEAKER_01]: You try to be unseen because you know that your presence will disturb certain people.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are certain servants that are assigned to
[SPEAKER_01]: Attend to you, and you're okay with them knowing your presence, but you're very private, you bathe alone, you do not like being surprised, and so basically what you have done is you have taught yourself how to be very stealthy, and also how to
[SPEAKER_01]: Be very depth and clever with your hands.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think most of your abilities are very innate abilities.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not a trained pickpocket, per se, but you've trained yourself on how to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to go into the kitchen and get some food without the cook knowing.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to go and get your clothing without...
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to do everything without nobody knowing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so in a lot of ways, you're kind of like a ghost around the castle.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And even though it's a little disconcerting to most people, they would rather you not be seen as well and you just be the ghost in...
[SPEAKER_01]: And you and your mother have basically been isolating yourselves in a particular wing of the palace for a long time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very nice part of the palace.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want for nothing there, and you have access to libraries, and you have spent a lot of time there educating yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: But again, it's all pretty much self-education.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say that you have an intricate knowledge of the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: You study and pour over the maps a lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a knowledge of your family's history very well because you poured over that a lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oftentimes trying to figure out if any of these guys could possibly be your father.
[SPEAKER_01]: To no avail.
[SPEAKER_01]: But
[SPEAKER_01]: You're also very interested in the way things run.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your interest is for several reasons.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the reasons is that you've always thought your uncle would give you something to do, and he just never has.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any thoughts?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's all my questions, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's the background.